you won the Oscar for it but there's
something about these physical
transformation roles when when an actor
does something where you realize like
they're literally torturing themselves
how would you get down to how much did
you weigh I weighed 135 and look you
know this I was not torturing myself I
was militant the hardest part was making
the damn Choice it was my responsibility
if I looked like I do now playing Ron
Woodruff in Dallas Buyers Club you are
out of the movie the first frame oh
[ __ ] he doesn't he's not stage four
HIV come out what's my job I had to lose
the weight once I made my mind up I did
the smart thing I gave myself five
months I got on a diet where I'd have
metapioca pudding or whatever three eggs
in the egg whites in the morning five
ounce of fish a couple vegetables for
lunch five ounces cup of vegetables for
dinner as much wine as I wanted to drink
and I lost 2.5 pounds a week like
clockwork no exercise as much wine as
you wanted to drink much is a one what
kind of diet is this it worked